is the first program of its kind in our
state as the Clark County coroner's
office is teaming up with UNLV to begin
a forensic fellowship program Mary Jane
beliesza joins us in studio Mary Jane
this has been in the works for quite
some time hasn't it
Kirsten the approval process for this
program took more than a year to
complete as this national accreditation
will help fill an important void in the
medical field
Clark County Medical coroner Melanie
Rouse is part of a 24-hour staff working
to identify your loved ones working in
the coroner's office is a tough job with
the need to pay attention to the fine
details we really have the ability to
ensure that we're effectively writing
the last chapter of somebody's life and
that we are providing closure back to
families she's the only Corner in Clark
County and one of over 70 staff members
that will help train graduate students
studying forensic pathology with only
500 forensic Pathologists actively
working in the United States at least
100 vacancies still need to be filled
Nationwide we have many that are
entering into the retirement age so that
in itself creates some challenges also
the position in itself wasn't as well
supported in other areas throughout the
country a new fellowship program with
the Kirk accordion school of medicine at
UNLV along with the coroner's office is
working to bridge that Gap I'm just
thrilled to see more and more of these
programs being offered and that I can
actually be a part of that but it's just
it's incredible Dr Kate Martin the
associate Dean for graduate medical
education at Kirk accordion says the
goal is to have two students fellowships
in general tend to be on the smaller
side residency programs are generally
larger so two trainees two graduates a
year will certainly add up over time and
this program will do more than just fill
the Nationwide shortage but will help us
locally we want to provide these
training opportunities so we can not
only recruit the best and brightest but
also retain them here to care for the
community and I think the opportunity to
find students early on in as they're
developing their career path and get
them interested in this the better off
it'll become the community as a whole
now this program is a year long and it's
for medical students entering their
fifth year residency
thank you Mary Jane the first student is
expected to begin training in this
program in July of 2024.